oh ho we got the car I really can't
price this that's a doped up to fans are
always doped us he didn't get it boiling
bit in if I had some scissors I'd do it
right now my name is Freddie I'm a
barber I cut hair out of manly and Sons
barber shop over on Sunset and Alvarado
in Los Angeles my name is Nick Romero
I'm a master barber we're cutting hair
for about 18 years now I got a barber
shop down in San Diego California we're
looking at a couple of guys see who has
the most expensive haircut
sometimes the expensive haircut doesn't
really mean that it looks the best it's
all about detailing intricacy you know
the timing may be the barber is too busy
maybe he's not as busy all that's
included in an expensive haircut cutting
here for so long you tend to see some of
the small things that actually make that
precise cut that costs and that somebody
a customers want to pay more money for
so there's a lot of factors that go into
an expensive haircut so it looks like
you got something you got some product
in here right yeah looks like we got
some texture work up top it's a basic
undercut ran it on the neckline the line
in the back that I'm looking at you can
see one side looks around the other side
[Music]
I'm gonna say like 25 dollars looks like
you got an X shape as well I want to say
the haircut cost around 35 40 bucks Matt
Matt Matt Matt your haircut was much
longer than a week ago
today it looks like it's grown out a
little bit so you've had a haircut here
you can see here with the comb-over
there's a lot more hair here on the side
and traditionally the barbers are
supposed to blend this into the side
here he didn't get it blended in find
some scissors I'd do it right now taper
neckline sweep Dover fairly easy cut to
me it looks like doesn't take much time
I'm guessing these la haircuts are like
30 40 and up you know even for basic so
I'm gonna guess this was about maybe $20
I want to say about why not cut this
isn't oka oh ho we got the copy and this
cut was done today
you've got else today's haircut that's
what I would have read it for now okay I
like this
recipes Cobian geez that's a
good-looking haircut I like it see I'm
gonna design free I could do design so
you gotta look at my page Rock mix on
Instagram you see all my designs it's a
nice fade you've got some line of work
you got some you know she's a work up
top you got some product in it as well
you feed it in from the beer the
mustache is good so the design work
that's apart from the haircut I mean I
know what I would charge and I unless
he's a friend of yours and hooking you
up with a good price I would say about
50 or 60 I want to say like total 65 now
the line hasn't seen a barber shop in
over a month where I maybe like two
months
I really can't price this looks like a
fairly easy cut to me doesn't really
take much time just the normal
gentleman's got almost soo here I'm
assuming right when he got a cut
originally being that he hasn't gotten a
haircut in a while you know I would say
the barbershop that he would be going to
would probably be like a ten nine okay
10 to 15 only because you don't go to
the shop and I'm not here to like pass
judgement on you I'm just don't have a
haircut you know and this is a haircut
video I'll say one thing though my hair
normally gets very very long and we have
very long time cut so think of very long
email looking the Huggle bangs cuz you
know okay let me ask you this you just
sat in the chair we're about to cut your
hair
what do you want it's kind of shorter I
want to say 15 my brother yeah I would
love to attack this haircut I wish I had
my clippers on me right now it's a dope
cut two fades are always dope cuts just
like my man over here with the Kobe
designs you get the bird done got a
medium skin phase they use the curl
sponge on top you got some line up work
to some bear work done this was two days
ago
all right right right right right right
like that's not like you write this that
here could I cute so dope cut I want to
say it's about 40 bucks
forty-four five bucks I would say for
this haircut
thirty dollars but it looks good I like
it I like it yes sir
well after looking at all these haircuts
I'm gonna have to say to my man from
North
Hollywood definitely paid more for his
haircut because of the design the
nostalgia behind it he's the only one
other than my man here with a beard so
there's a lot more attention to detail
on that one all right
you said 25 for me I go to Floyd's 99
which is 27 so I guess it's 27 plus tip
so you said 30 so 30 35 flattered the
$20 cuz I cut my own hair
oh wait buzz it myself every once in a
while no way yeah we're dollars zero
dollars let me see and I now know to
fade the back so you did a good job here
thank you very much your self did this
guy's did a good barber how long you
been doing this since high school I've
needed a haircut one day so I kind of
just okay that's incredible zero dollars
how much your barbers the North
Hollywood charge you for this one I need
to know are you gonna be off because
it's really cool bad it was $55 55 bucks
if you think I think I guess 30 30 and
30 right 60 55 I said 60 that's another
second wins kind of pretty good man all
right let's see how much does non
haircut was right the $10 haircut but I
didn't get it in LA I weights like at
home too expensive haircut once every
three months he's like I'm coming home
mom and he just goes get the haircut and
go see her oh yeah my mom hates it when
I come over they all your hair is the
worst like I know yeah this cut would be
30 bucks that's true yeah that's true 40
bucks probably
oh no I'm not gonna say you genius and I
got the days right right two days ago
and it was two days ago I'll tell you
I've been doing it for a long time man
but it looks good I do like it yeah yeah
that's a steal hope you tip them good oh
yeah there you have it five people and
except for one the $20 I did it myself
at a home cut I got him up I got him on
pretty much right two to five dollars
off or on actually what surprised me
about two of the haircuts
one of the gentlemen said cut his
and well I think that yeah the for that
there was a $45 [ __ ] that I guess right
you said was 25 bucks so yeah two of
them two of them coming off there's a
lot of different opportunities out there
when you're at your barber shop to talk
to your barber and figure out what you
need to get done and when you're in the
chair you know go get a haircut
[Music]